Yeah,
I think one dilemma you always have is
a profession really depends on our being
able to publish our work in peer review
journals.
So what gets published,
it's really been gone over with a fine
tooth comb and so we review each other's
papers and
you have to decide when you have a
conflict of interest or not.
And if someone's work is too close to
yours,
if they're a competitor,
I think you have to stay away from it
because there's an obvious conflict of
interest,
a little bit less obvious if you have
people,
uh,
who's the people whose papers who wrote
the papers from your lab there,
former postdocs or students.
I think that's also like a conflict of
interest.
And I think it's a,
it's uh,
there are gray areas work that's sort of
close to your work,
but I mean where,
where do you draw the line of when it's
okay to review someone else's work?
We at a paper or a grant,
uh,
and when is it not?
And when it's self interest,
a creeping in.
And,
um,
you know,
I think it's very important that the
peer review process,
is this the best thing we have a that it
be a,
as pure as possible.
It's never going to be perfect,
but I think it's worth thinking about.
And,
uh,
and it poses,
poses dilemmas on a regular basis.